de lo que quiero hablar en este vídeo es
de lo que significa el gradiente en el
contexto de la gráfica de una función y
vimos en el vídeo en el vídeo anterior
definimos lo que es el gradiente así que
tomemos una función por aquí tomemos la
función f de x esteban esta función va a
tener dos entradas y digamos que esta
función sea x cuadrada más que cuadrada
que de hecho es la que grafica do por
acá de este lado así que para esta
función tenemos una entrada de dos
dimensiones verdad podríamos pensar que
la entrada está en el plano x de verdad
y la salida está en una dimensión verdad
que es justamente la altura de la
gráfica verdad y lo que definimos en el
vídeo anterior como el gradiente en
realidad lo podíamos pensar como un
operador verdad esto
esto significa que tomamos una función y
nos da como salida otra función verdad y
para denotar al gradiente utilizamos
este triángulo invertido verdad
nos define el gradiente así que decimos
que el gradiente de la función f en
realidad nos da otra función verdad que
también depende de esta misma entrada x
pero en este caso nos da una salida con
valores vectoriales verdad entonces las
componentes de nuestra salida sería la
derivada parcial de nuestra función con
respecto a x y la derivada parcial de
nuestra función con respecto a ye muy
bien entonces nuestra salida es ésta así
que para una función como ésta a la hora
de digamos de calcular explícitamente el
gradiente veamos qué es lo que obtenemos
nosotros tenemos que derivar primero con
respecto a x verdad entonces la derivada
con respecto a x de x cuadrada es 2x y
luego derivamos ye cuadrada con respecto
a x pero esto se hace cero verdad así
que aquí tenemos simplemente la primera
entrada y luego la segunda entrada es 2
verdad porque tendríamos que derivar ye
cuadrada que cuya derivada es 2 y la
derivada
x cuadrada con respecto a 0 porque esto
sería como una constante para fines de
derivar con respecto a y entonces al
derivar lo nos da simplemente 0 verdad
así que esta función que obtenemos lo
que es el gradiente verdad en realidad
como ya mencionamos es tiene una entrada
de dos dimensiones xy verdad que puede
ser un punto en este plano pero nos da
como salida un ver un vector y puede
visualizarse muy bien esto como un campo
vectorial y ya tenemos un vídeo sobre
campos vectoriales y si no te sientes
muy seguro de qué significa esto puedes
revisarlo pero lo que quiero que hagas
es esto marcan un momento digamos darle
una pausa este vídeo si es necesario y
tratar de pensar verdad cómo sería el
campo vectorial que que está
representado por nuestro gradiente
verdad entonces esto lo mostraré en un
momento pero quiero que trates de pensar
cómo sería la salida en el plano xy de
este campo vectorial que es 2 x 2
muy bien
así que espero que ya lo hayas hecho que
lo hayas tratado de pensar por tu propia
cuenta y aquí es lo que obtenemos es un
montón de vectores que están apuntando
hacia afuera en dirección contraria al
origen verdad y la razón básica para
esto es que si tenemos un punto de
entrada digamos que tiene coordenadas x
entonces el vector que está representado
por este punto de entrada digamos si
partimos de aquí del origen entonces
este vector se vería más o menos así
pero la salida es dos veces ese vector
así que cuando lo colocamos digamos
anclado al punto original obtenemos algo
que es del doble del tamaño del vector
original verdad y apuntando en la misma
dirección que es hacia fuera del origen
así que aquí en realidad lo he dibujado
bastante bastante mal verdad por
supuesto cuando dibujamos campos
vectoriales no solemos dibujarlos a
escalas sino que los re escalamos verdad
de digamos para que se vean un poco más
pequeños pero utilizamos colores para
indicar la longitud de estos vectores
verdad aquí el color es lo que indica la
longitud así que podríamos pensar
estos tipos rojos de por acá son muy muy
largos mientras que los que son azules
en realidad son muy cortos y bueno la
pregunta es qué tiene que ver esto con
la gráfica de una función y en realidad
es una interpretación genial así que
imaginemos que estamos caminando digamos
sobre esta gráfica verdad imaginen que
que somos digamos este gente que le
gusta el montañismo entonces digamos
como una montaña de verdad así que si
nos colocamos a nosotros mismos digamos
en este punto sobre la gráfica
entonces nos colocamos en este punto y
nos preguntamos qué dirección deberíamos
seguir para incrementar nuestra altitud
de forma digamos la más rápida posible
así que podríamos caminar hacia acá
arriba a verdad y si proyectamos este
punto digamos hacia el espacio de
entradas entonces este punto que tenemos
acá arriba este vector este que nos está
indicando digamos el ascenso más rápido
verdad entonces para esta gráfica
debería tener sentido que nos estamos
dirigiendo justamente a digamos lejos
del origen verdad que vamos a borrar
esto así que así que si nos fijamos en
todo esto pero desde digamos desde abajo
cualquier punto que digamos sobre el que
nos coloquemos en la montaña desde
nuestra gráfica por aquí si queremos
incrementar digamos de forma más rápida
deberíamos dirigirnos en dirección
contraria al origen verdad esta es
digamos la dirección más pronunciada y
todos esos vectores también están
apuntando digamos hacia afuera del
origen así que la gente diría que el
gradiente apunta en la dirección
del ascenso más pronunciado así que esto
vale la pena anotarlo esta sería la
dirección la dirección del ascenso del
ascenso más pronunciado
más
pronunciado
la dirección del ascenso más pronunciado
así que fijémonos en cómo se ve esto en
el contexto digamos de otro ejemplo así
que pongamos otra gráfica por aquí que
pongamos otra gráfica por aquí y
pongamos su campo vectorial así que esta
gráfica del todo digamos son puros
valores negativos verdad todo está por
debajo del plano xy y podemos notar que
cerca del pico verdad todos estos
vectores están apuntando digamos justo
en la dirección digamos en la que
podemos ir subiendo esta colina verdad y
nos dice más o menos como hay que subir
este pico para poder ir de forma más
rápida verdad así que sólo para que te
des una idea puedes ver que justo por
aquí por encima verdad todos los
vectores alrededor nos dicen que vayamos
colina arriba verdad así que cada vector
nos está diciendo de qué forma podríamos
caminar para incrementar la altitud
sobre la gráfica de la manera más rápida
así que esta es la dirección del ascenso
más pronunciado y eso es lo que esta
dirección significa verdad pero que
significaría
longitud bueno si nos fijamos digamos en
estos vectores rojos de por aquí el rojo
significa que deberían ser considerados
como vectores muy muy grandes verdad y
la gráfica misma por ejemplo aquí el
punto que corresponde a la gráfica
simplemente está fuera de la pantalla
para nosotros verdad justo porque esta
gráfica realmente se vuelve muy
pronunciada y muy negativa de forma más
rápida verdad así que los puntos
corresponden digamos a son puntos que
corresponden a tener pendientes muy
pronunciadas mientras que los que son de
color azul por ejemplo por aquí en
realidad tienen una pendiente muy muy
poco pronunciada verdad así que a medida
que nos vamos acercando a la punta
verdad las cosas empiezan se empiezan a
nivelar y así la longitud de nuestro
vector gradiente de hecho se vuelve cada
vez más corto verdad así que esto nos
indica qué tan pronunciada es esa
dirección verdad en el ascenso digamos
en la dirección del ascenso más
pronunciado y una de las cosas que
quisiera remarcar aquí es que no tiene
mucho sentido fijarnos directamente
digamos con
derivadas parciales verdad con la que
consumimos nuestro vector no podríamos
tener la noción inmediata de que nos
indica la dirección del ascenso más
rápido verdad y de hecho así va a ser
pero vamos a hablar de esto más adelante
y para para poder hacer una conexión
mucho más clara con algunos algunos
conceptos que veremos más adelante como
lo que es la derivada direccional verdad
pero no es inmediato a menos de que se
hace algún tipo de de genio muy
intuitivo no creo que la conexión sea
tan obvia en principio pero ya lo
veremos en su debido momento nos vemos
en el próximo vídeo